and so why did you leave was that be why
yeah it really ultimately was because I
felt like I spent my whole life
supporting your dreams
with a man for 15 years with children
and you just decided to leave because it
wasn't okay there's a multitude of
things that obviously go into it 15
years a lot of baggage right there's
other things that I will not have to
look at his bag it just a lot of time
and effort it was a lot of time and
effort and I'll never I'll never take it
back I've learned some real life lessons
from that relationship honestly but it
also taught me that whoever I now get
with has to understand the type of
industry and what I'm doing they have to
be within my world so what do you think
it's going to look like for you now in
the Dayton Market as a single woman yeah
three children and and you right you
you've left them you left a man that
committed to you you had three three of
your children you've left him you're now
on a dating Market with three children
what do you think it's gonna look like
for you on a daily Market does it
but that's where I think that it's crazy
because I think I because I I understand
I've been in a long-term relationship
I've come out of it it didn't work
um and you do look at the time and I
think that was the biggest frustration
the time the effort the years the just
everything
um but then it's do you then stay with
somebody
and just settle down and just be that
person and yes okay yeah that's why then
70 of people
duties duties more important than
happiness it's not about you like once
you have a family it's not about you
anymore you you come second to the
family and I can respect that I can to
an extent yeah ultimately we are all
individuals of our own purpose in life
one at a time one at a time
if your children aren't unhappy or your
house isn't happy
do you stay together because it's your
duty and have unhappy kids that have to
deal with a trauma when they're older
than their parents well it's traumatic
to have the dad out of the home well you
put you put your kid in every
statistical disadvantage if you take the
father out of the home if you have a
great dad that's just about to say that
does great co-parent and don't just see
their child like every weekend or every
other weekend has an active you know
four days a week like involved and can I
pick it back quickly Rings because I
could piggyback right my point is
um if you start a relationship and you
guys have a great Bond as far as a
friendship ultimately in the end of that
little demise of the relationship you
can still Salvage something I have a
great co-parent in a relationship with
my children's Dad when I go out dating
I'm not looking for somebody to replace
him or be a father figure to my children
I'm looking for someone I can fulfill my
needs because I'm at a mature age where
I understand myself sexually I
understand my myself as far as my
ambitions in life and like so many other
things go into that right do you want
him to know your children your new man
um yeah ultimately at some point but
it's not something that I'm going to be
like pushing towards do you understand
see this is the thing it's like and this
is what I was saying what it looks like
for you now out on The Dating Market
because men that you're going to be
coming into is going to be coming into
your situation is now looking at you and
I'm not saying you're not a great mother
I'm not saying you're not a great person
but men do not look men are looking at
the long term and they're looking at the
actual package and they're saying how
many children she got yeah what kind of
trauma is that
and they're gonna hear 15 years with
someone you said is a great father right
and was a good husband or boyfriend I
know you didn't get married but but and
they're gonna see that as a lack of
loyalty and selfishness
that's how men that's how men see it
because because a lot of men like the
reason women leave 70 to 80 percent of
the time
um on top of that if you're a college
educated women leave 90 of the time so a
lot of men are looking at this dating
market and just seeing a lot of selfish
women that put them ourselves above the
family go ahead you had a question what
how does that Dynamic change when it's
the man that also has children because a
lot of we're talking about the woman I
know Kevin Samuels I did watch a lot of
his stuff like we're looking at so men
don't find it acceptable if you're a
mother I personally don't have children
yet but don't find it acceptable if
you're a mother but they may have
children of their own so how does that
um actually diver how does that balance
out Sarah you have a child do you want
to date do you want to date someone with
a kid
um that's my decision I'd prefer not to
but if it happened
I prefer not to I'm just going to say I
prefer not to
um because I've already done it I've
done it before and I've done it for like
10 years so I'm like I've done it it's
not the same yeah and it's not the same
no it's not in you yeah it's not the
same as a father it's not the same as
because
fathers generally someone said how sorry
it's gone no go on yeah right do you
want me to answer it please my love
um because when a father has their child
they have their child
um not like the mother has their child
the the mother has the child the father
and due to unless you're an actual
single parent father right you don't
have the child so A man also when he's
looking for a woman is not looking for a
woman to become stepfather to his child
he's not looking for that well a woman
generally is looking for a man to become
stepfather to her kids well and and
there's a bat where you can't undo how
we are biologically and in in in history
if a man had children that was a sign of
pre-selection from other women so that
that's a sign oh he can take care of
those kids he can take care of those
women he can take care of me too so
we're we're attracted to That We're Men
um they they don't like girls with a
high body count because that signals
that the kid possibly could not be
theirs and so if there's actual that's
body count if there's evidence that if
there's an actual child that's that's a
sign that she slept with other dudes or
and that also goes back to cheating when
men men and women cheat differently
because when men cheat there's no
question about paternity or maternity
about the child when women cheat there's
always a question of paternity so women
think they can cheat the same as men
which is why you've never seen the Maury
Show and there's a mother on there like
am I the mother of the baby no I've
never seen that right but you've always
seen am I the father of the baby because
no one's questioning that so when women
cheat it's totally different to when
Menchie I no I definitely agree with
that a hundred percent when it comes
down to paternity but are we are you
saying sorry
um
that
as as a man with a child you you expect
a woman to date you with your child but
you wouldn't no it's her choice
it's her choice but it's it's more what
is it it's supply and demand right so so
women care less about men's kids wow
yeah we're like obviously in percentage
Yeah I'm 25 right so there's girls my
age that are willing to date guys with
kids as long as he could take care of
them
don't get me wrong like they're not well
some girls still date broke guys with
kids but typically
wow but but in general but men it's just
not the same because it's like when a
guy thinks about you like with another
dude it makes them sick like they just
don't they don't want to know they don't
yeah yeah like
yeah and so and you got actual evidence
and that's just a girl being with
another guy when you got actual children
yeah like what in the animal kingdom
they kill the children yeah they take
the wife kill the children
and also a guy when he's coming into
your life he knows whoever consciously
or subconsciously he's gonna have to
take care of the household and those
household that household includes your
children yeah right a woman who's coming
into my life knows that I've already got
my household on on look she ain't gonna
take care of my child I want somebody
that's going to be there for your child
like a I mean to some degree but I don't
really require it
no but I've got everything when it comes
to my child I've got everything that I
need for my I don't need you to come
here and say oh I'm gonna be a no you're
not gonna be stepmom now you're not
require that that's fine don't worry
about it no but men because men when
they take over households there are
children in that there are children
within the household as a man he knows
it's his responsibility to take care of
the household and there are children in
that household which means those are
going to be his responsibility
you should want somebody that is going
to come in and want to care and give
love to your child yeah
sorry would you allow your stepdad um or
your new boyfriend to Discipline Your
Child yeah okay
[Applause]
but that's because this whole crazy
thing of I'm gonna keep this separate
but I'm gonna try and date and be with
somebody but I have a child question
follow-up follow-up question so if you
if your child was acting up okay and you
did not feel like it required him like
hitting the kid but he did
would you would you there's other ways
of discipline no no no no no no no no
but but see that's that's saying that's
okay so you're right so you're you're
right slap my child yeah would you give
him that that Authority it depends what
has been okay so so it's a no so the
answer but this is okay wait wait let me
let me finish so so but what you're
actually saying is he doesn't get the
authority because you want to decide but
but like relinquishing control is saying
you get to decide and you get to pick
the guy so you you'd get to determine if
he would be a good step dad but it's if
he fills that role does he get all the
authority even if you don't agree I hope
that I picked the right one because if
my child knocks over a drink and it
spills and you slap my child there's
something wrong with it right but you're
going to the extreme we're not talking
about this yeah
but I just want to know what the thing
because you could say oh they touch
something and I want to slap them but
okay what's the level of it because it
so right right but we're not we're not
going all the way to the extreme maybe
maybe he's being he's talking back he's
saying you're not my dad like being
extremely disrespectful and he he thinks
he should be able to slap the kid okay
well obviously there's an extreme
situation going on so I'm Gonna Leave
You to handle that and if I disagree we
can talk about it later amongst us
if you're in my house of course for you
to be around my child and just we've
been together for a while I was just
like that's not just something where
we've met I've met somebody they've come
here
I was with a woman I was with the woman
who had a child right this is anecdote
evidence right I was with a woman who
had a child right I was with her for 10
years and I knew at every step whether
it be a conscious conversation or a
subconscious one that I was only
supposed to go so far with the
discipline of that child yeah right and
mothers know that if they bring a man
into their house their home the men feel
that they know they can only go so far
with the discipline of that child
however that man gets 100 percent of the
responsibility as a dad right but he
doesn't get 100 percent of the
responsibility when it comes to the
discipline and the guidance of that
child and I'm saying it's a and that's
why a lot of men are saying it's a bad
deal for men to be with women who
already have children as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible